Sie sind gute Gefährten.
*Fiepen*
Können ihre Größe verändern.
Oder sind einfach
die besten Taschendiebe der Welt.
Zum Kinostart vom 3. Teil
der fantastischen Tierwesen
zeigen wir euch
die spannendsten Exemplare.
Und welche ihrer Eigenschaften
in der realen Welt vorkommen.
*epische Musik*
Tag!
Jack Pop hier!
Heute in einer
fast magischen Umgebung.
Von hier steigen wir hinab
in den Koffer von Newt Scamander.
Wir schauen uns
fantastische Tierwesen an
und ihre Vorbilder
aus der realen Welt.
Ich habe mir einen Experten
dazu rangeholt.
Ihr kennt ihn aus unserer DC-Folge.
Karim ist da, hi.
Hi, danke, dass ich da sein darf.
Eigentlich bin ich
wegen meiner Frau hier.
Die ist Mega-Fan der Filme.
Als Tierarzt muss ich meinen Kopf
anschalten beim Film schauen:
Wo ist das reale Vorbild
für die fantastischen Tierwesen?
Witzig, dass du es sagst.
So muss es den Leuten vom London
Natural History Museum gegangen sein.
Die haben eine Ausstellung
dazu gemacht.
Ziemlich interessant.
Absoluter Traumjob.
So cool, wenn man
wissenschaftliche Erkenntnisse
auf was Fantastisches anwenden kann.
Die haben gute Beispiele gefunden.
Ein paar davon schauen wir uns an.
Wir wollen auch
eigene Äquivalente finden.
Um uns da die Auswahl zu erleichtern,
haben wir uns eine Expertin
für die magische Welt dazu geholt.
Alwaysxcaro.
*epische Musik*
Ich freue mich,
euch meine Lieblingstiere
aus den Filmen zu präsentieren.
Wir starten mit den Occamys.
Sie sind eine Mischung
aus Schlange und Vogel.
Und sie legen Eier aus purem Silber.
Warum sie das tun?
Keine Ahnung.
Außerdem können sie ihre Körpergröße
an ihren Lebensraum anpassen.
Sie können sich auf die Größe
eines Dachbodens ausdehnen,
passen aber auch in eine Teekanne.
Danke, Caro.
Ich kenne weder Reptilien mit Flügeln
noch Tiere mit silbernen Eiern.
Noch jemanden, der schrumpfen kann.
Obwohl?
Kraken können das.
Es gibt geile Videos, wo ein Krake
durch ein Schlüsselloch geht.
Übelst krass.
So semi-krass würde ich sagen.
Die haben nicht mal ein Skelett.
Nichts gegen Kraken, die sind super.
Die passen da easy durch.
Krasser finde ich den Schleim-Aal.
Der hat eine Skelettstruktur
und taucht in der Ausstellung auf.
Sie passen durch alles durch,
was nur halb so groß ist.
Sie haben eine lockere Haut.
Die schieben einen Teil vorne durch,
das Blut sammelt sich hinten.
Dann geht das Blut nach vorne
und der Rest kommt hinterher.
Total abgefahren.
Ich dacht immer, die hätten Schleim
wie eine Schnecke.
Aber der Schleim
ist eher wie Spinnenseide.
Also eher fest.
Total crazy.
Wow, okay.
Aber auch eklig.
Ist es sehr.
Ist halt der Schleim-Aal.
Wir können festhalten: Das Prinzip
funktioniert im echten Leben.
Wie Occamys in eine Teekanne können,
kann sich der Schleim-Aal
durch kleinere Öffnungen quetschen.
Da haut der Vergleich total gut hin.
Was sie nicht können, ist,
tatsächlich schrumpfen.
Gibt es da ein Beispiel für Tiere,
die schrumpfen können?
Gibt es, sogar Wirbeltiere.
Die Galapagos-Meerechse.
Die kommt von den Galapagos-Inseln.
Die sind bis zu 1 m groß.
Also richtig große Dinger.
Die können bei Nahrungsknappheit
um 20% schrumpfen.
20%?
Ein Fünftel?
Das wäre bei meiner Körpergröße
so 30-35 cm.
Schon ordentlich.
Krass, oder?
Die Echsen
machen das bei Nahrungsknappheit.
Die ernähren sich sonst von Algen.
Es gibt das Wetterphänomen El Niño,
das warmes Wasser anspült,
ohne Algen.
Dann müssen sie schrumpfen.
Durch den Klimawandel
kommt El Niño immer häufiger vor.
Deshalb ist das wichtig.
Ah okay.
Wie machen die das genau?
Wie funktioniert das Schrumpfen?
Das wissen wir noch nicht.
Man vermutet,
es ist hormonell gesteuert.
Die bauen nicht nur Fett
und Muskulatur ab,
sondern die Knochen werden kürzer.
Echt?
Ja.
Beim menschlichen Knochenschwund
geht es eher um die Knochendichte.
Genau, wie bei Astronauten.
Aber bei denen nimmt die Länge ab?
Ja.
Wenn El Niño vorbei ist,
es mehr Algen gibt,
werden die Knochen länger.
Life finds a way.
Wir müssen aber nicht
auf die Galapagos-Insel gehen.
Auch hier gibt es Tiere,
die schrumpfen können.
Z.B. die Spitzmaus.
Stimmt, das erinnert mich
an unsere Ant-Man-Folge.
Da kamen die auch vor.
Die Folge verlinke ich euch.
Da ging es auch ums Schrumpfen.
Die müssen permanent essen.
Alle 2-3 Stunden müssen die essen,
sonst verhungern die.
Voll stressig.
Das geht im Winter nicht.
Sie senken ihren Energiebedarf,
indem sie schrumpfen.
Bis zu 15%.
Schädel, Organe, alles schrumpft.
Total abgefahren.
Wir können an der Stelle festhalten:
Es gibt Tiere, die schrumpfen können.
Wenn auch nicht so schnell und extrem
wie bei den Occamys.
*epische Musik*
Den Niffler
lernen wir als Ersten kennen.
Es ist das 1. Wesen, das einem
bei den Filmen in den Kopf kommt.
Er ist süchtig nach allem,
was glänzt.
Ein bisschen
wie ein störrisches Kind.
Kann nerven, aber man kann ihm
nicht böse sein, weil er so süß ist.
Niffler können gut graben.
Sie werden als Trüffelschweine
eingesetzt,
um nach Schätzen zu suchen.
Diebisch, störrisch,
können gut graben,
süchtig nach Schmuck
und trotzdem total niedlich.
Welches Tier
verbindet alle diese Eigenschaften?
Alle zusammen: keins.
Aber rein optisch
ist es ein Schnabeltier.
Schnabeltiere sind Säugetiere,
legen aber trotzdem Eier.
Ich habe noch ein paar Fakten,
die ihr noch nicht wusstet.
Schnabeltiere
sind extrem gute Gräber.
Sie können
bis zu 20 m lange Bauten graben.
Außerdem sind Schnabeltiere giftig.
What?
Die sollen doch niedlich
und süß sein.
Warum sind die giftig?
Die sind niedlich,
bis die Sexy Time kommt.
Die Männchen haben einen Giftsporn
am Hinterbein.
Der ist in der Paarungszeit giftig.
Der wird nur eingesetzt, wenn sie
sich um ein Weibchen prügeln.
Falls man als Mensch
dazwischenkommt,
ist es für uns giftig.
Nicht tödlich, aber schmerzhaft.
Krass, wusste ich nicht.
Nächster Fakt: Woran erinnert dich
der Schnabel vom Schnabeltier?
An eine Ente.
Meine Lieblingstiere.
Aber der ist nicht fest
wie bei einer Ente.
Der ist komisch weich.
Schnabeltiere
jagen nämlich unter Wasser.
Dabei haben sie
die Augen und Ohren zu.
Damit sie
die Beute wahrnehmen können,
haben sie im Schnabel
Elektro- und Mechano-Rezeptoren.
Sie merken Impulse von Beutetieren
und Bewegungen des Wassers.
Wow, das ist super-praktisch.
Total.
Ein bisschen creepy, aber praktisch.
Noch abgefahrener ist,
wo die Milch herkommt.
Es sind ja Säugetiere,
aber sie haben keine Zitzen,
sondern schwitzen ihre Milch
aus den Achseln.
What?
Die kleinen Schnabeltiere
lecken die Milch aus dem Fell.
Okay.
Ihr dachtet,
ihr bekommt Wissenschaft.
Karim meint, ihr wolltet
die Freakshow des Tierreichs haben.
Korrekt, 3 Punkte für Hufflepuff.
Okay, Karim.
Wir haben viel
über Schnabeltiere gelernt.
Zurück zum Niffler.
Wenn es um das Diebische geht,
denke ich zuerst an eine Elster.
Die haben nur einen schlechten Ruf.
Die sind nicht diebisch.
Das kommt wohl daher, dass Elstern
manchmal Drähte klauen zum Nestbau.
Das wurde wissenschaftlich
untersucht
in einer Studie der Uni Exeter.
Die haben den Elstern
3 Näpfe angeboten.
Einmal mit Futter,
mit glänzenden Schrauben
und mit matten Schrauben.
Schrauben waren uninteressant.
Sie gingen zum Futter.
Diebische Elstern gibt es nicht.
Also ein Mythos.
Elstern sind nicht so diebisch.
Für die Londoner Ausstellung
haben Wissenschaftler:innen
andere Tierarten gefunden,
mit absurdem Sammelverhalten.
Z.B. die Wegwespe.
Die sammelt, kein Scheiß,
tote Ameisen
und stapelt sie
vor ihrem Nesteingang.
Why?
Aus menschlicher Perspektive
klingt es morbide.
Für die Wespe macht es Sinn,
weil ihr Nest
nach Ameisenkolonie riecht.
Als Fressfeind möchte ich mich
nicht mit den Ameisen anlegen.
Die bleiben vom Gelege weg.
Hätte ich gar keinen Bock drauf.
Wir gehen weg vom Morbiden
hin zum Schönen,
zum Seidenlaubenvogel in Australien.
Der hat zur Paarungszeit
die gleiche Sammelleidenschaft
wie der Niffler.
Für die Dekoration seines Nests
sucht er sich etwas Seltenes:
die Farbe Blau.
Blaue Beeren, blaue Federn,
aber auch Dinge von Menschen
wie blaue Glasscherben.
Das legt er in sein Nest.
Total abgefahren:
Mit den blauen Beeren
malt er sein Nest an.
Total crazy.
Also wie ein Werkzeug.
Genau.
Dann können wir festhalten:
Der Niffler ist in der realen Welt
eine Kombination aus Schnabeltier
und Seidenlaubenvogel.
Aber so sweet wie der Niffler
ist natürlich niemand.
*epische Musik*
Das beste Tier zum Schluss:
Pickett, der Bowtruckle,
der Gefährte von Newt Scamander.
In freier Wildbahn
findet man Bowtruckle an Bäumen,
deren Holz
für Zauberstäbe verwendet wird.
Bowtruckle haben die Aufgabe,
Bäume zu beschützen.
So niedlich sie aussehen, wenn du
dich an einem Baum vergreifst,
werden sie dir mit den kleinen
Fingern die Augen auskratzen.
Sie lassen sich ablenken
mit ihren Lieblingssnacks
Holzläusen oder Feen-Eiern.
Feen-Eier habe ich immer dabei.
Nee, Spaß beiseite.
Eine super Ergänzung:
Bowtruckle und Baum.
Bowtruckle hat einen Ort zum Leben
und der Baum
ist vor Angreifern geschützt.
Voll praktisch, so eine Symbiose.
Das gibt es in der Natur häufig.
Ein gutes Beispiel
sind Flötenakazie und Ameisen.
Die Flötenakazie
ist ein Baum aus Ostafrika.
Da ist es trocken.
Aber die Flötenakazie hat bei
größter Trockenheit grüne Blätter.
Das wollen Elefanten und Giraffen
wegsnacken.
Um sich zu schützen,
hat die Flötenakazie ein Gift.
Das reicht aber nicht.
Sie geht eine Symbiose
mit Ameisen ein.
Was machen die Ameisen?
Die Akazie
muss die Ameisen anlocken.
Dafür bildet sie Hohlräume,
in denen sich Nektar sammelt.
Die Ameisen wohnen dort
und können sich ernähren.
Kommt eine Giraffe und zupft
an den Blättern, vibriert es.
Die Ameisen denken,
sie werden bedroht.
Dann vertreiben sie die Giraffe
mit Geruch und beißen sie halt.
Da hätte ich auch keinen Bock drauf.
Das Spannende ist:
Die Ameisen haben was davon.
Sie werden ernährt.
Aber die Akazie
kommt nicht ohne Ameisen klar.
Wissenschaftler:innen
haben herausgefunden:
Wenn Elefanten und Giraffen
wegbleiben,
hört die Akazie auf,
diese Hohlräume zu bilden.
Dann gehen die Ameisen weg.
Aber es kommen andere Insekten und
Parasiten, die der Akazie schaden.
Die Symbiose
funktioniert in beide Richtungen.
Daran sieht man, wie natürliche
Prozesse funktionieren,
die Komplexität.
Und wie eng
alles miteinander verbunden ist.
Das ist ein Teil der Ausstellung
im Londoner Natural History Museum.
Da gibt es einen Fokus darauf.
Wenn wir Glück haben, können wir
die Ausstellung bei uns erleben.
Die soll nämlich auf Tour gehen.
Bis es soweit ist,
könnt ihr sie virtuell anschauen.
Ich packe euch einen Link
in die Infobox.
Ansonsten bereiten wir uns
auf die Filme vor.
Bei euch Pflichtprogramm zu Hause?
Meine Frau wird drauf bestehen.
Mittlerweile habe ich auch Bock.
Wir freuen uns.
Ich würde sagen,
das war heute skurril,
auch ein bisschen eklig.
Aber auch niedlich und
ein bisschen magisch mit dir, Karim.
Danke, ich habe den Dreh mit dir
von meiner Liste abgehakt.
Link zu Karim
packe ich euch in die Infobox.
Genauso den Link zu Caro.
Auch an die ein großes Dankeschön.
Lasst gerne einen Kommentar
zur Folge da.
Ich les das total gern.
Vergesst nicht, den Kanal ...
... zu abonnieren
und die Glocke zu drücken.
YouTube kann er.
Dann sehen wir uns bald wieder.
Ich freue mich, tschau.
Habt ihr diesen Kerl vermisst?
In dieser Folge haben wir schon über
seine besondere Fähigkeit gesprochen.
Das Unsichtbarwerden.
Und hier schaut Karim
sich hässliche Tiere an.